We Begin obviously with this history
shaping history changing story from the
independent uh reports alleged non-human
alien corpses have been displayed to
Mexican politicians of the country's
Congress the two small alleged alien
corpses retrieved from uh Peru were
presented in windowed boxes in Mexico
City on Wednesday starting excitement
within the UFO conspiracy theorist
Community the event was spearheaded by a
journalist and ufologist Jamie massan
who testified under oath that the
mummified specimens are not part of our
terrestrial Evolution with almost a
third of their DNA remaining unknown
reported Mexican media the claims by the
self self-claimed ufologists have not
been proven and Mr masan has previously
been associated with claims of
discoveries that have later been
debunked
okay first of all
that's a very rude paragraph I have to
say so you're telling me if this guy
makes one Claim about aliens that's
that's debunked allegedly suddenly he's
not allowed to present evidence of
actual aliens that he finds like okay so
he made a claim about aliens that was
debunked and then he happened to find
real aliens what do you want him to do
you want him to not tell us about it
because he's he's he said well I've been
debunked one so now I'm disqualified
it's like you know I understand the boy
who cried wolf but if the boy cries wolf
and he lies and then the next day he
brings the wolf to you and says here's a
wolf
like are you gonna say no this is a
psyop right I mean think about it so uh
continuing at the public hearing Mr
masan showed U.S officials and members
of The Mexican government several videos
of UFOs and unidentified anomalous
phenomena before unveiling the alleged
alien corpses he said quote these
specimen are not part of our terrestrial
Evolution these aren't beings that were
found after UFO wreckage they were found
in an algae mines and were later
fossilized Mr masan told attendees the
specimens have been studied by
scientists at the autonomous National
University of Mexico who were able to
draw DNA evidence using radiocarbon
dating after comparisons were made to
other DNA samples it was found that over
30 percent of specimens DNA was unknown
and they also showed X-rays and they
said that bodies have eggs inside
uh while both were said to have implants
made of very rare metals
okay and also these were a thousand
years old they were able to date them to
a thousand years old now
so this is tremendous so we have actual
so now we have the final piece everyone
said
that UFO sightings that's not enough I'm
not convinced uh where the actual alien
bodies
well here you go here they are what do
you have to say now uh we have the
actual video if I'm unveiling the alien
corpses so let's put that up on the
screen
is
you can see them there in the boxes
laying very comfortably
if you don't speak Spanish what he's
saying is saying uh these are real
aliens
these are 100 real it's been proven it's
a fact
or what do you have to say now apologize
to Matt Walsh apologize to him he says
and he continues along that way uh so
I'm bilingual so a little bit of a
translation there so I'll tell you okay
so uh no put the put the picture back
what do you we have we have images of
actual aliens we take them off the
screen like would it put it on the
screen the entire time can we see the
images again of the aliens okay right
there so you you know what else do you
need to see that's the alien and that's
so and I want to tell you exactly what
happened I'll tell you exactly what
happened so first of all
we have to admit I think for a
thousand-year-old corpses uh you know
they're pretty cute little guys you know
and and I mean they look like uh Elf on
the Shelf or something uh like they
could be you know like they're your
friends who come to watch over you and I
can tell you just from my own analysis
that uh and you know after having
studied this I read the articles I've
looked at these aliens
um I've looked at the the DNA sequences
and what I can tell from my own research
and studies is that these were
definitely friendly aliens 100 100
guaranteed and that's again based on my
own research so these were these were
friendly little guys who came to Earth
and um you know I'm betting they had fun
little names like uh you know like beep
and Bop or something or probably their
names I'm guessing and so beep and Bob
came all this way and they were just
looking to make friends and they were
just one you know they wanted to hang
out and have a good time and I'll tell
you exactly what happened so they landed
in pre-columbian South America and that
is just
that's bad luck man that is that is not
where you want to be that's not the time
you want to be it's just they're off
they're off by a few thousand miles and
a few hundred years and uh they really
got the wrong side of that coin flip and
now this was In fairness to uh to Peru a
thousand years ago
this was a thousand years ago so if
you're it's a thousand years ago and
you're a tiny friendly alien from an
advanced civilization there's not going
to be anywhere on Earth that's great to
land there's not a not gonna be any
great options for you uh there's no
ideal spot on the planet at that time
but you probably would have been better
off with Medieval Europe
um
I mean you you know Medieval Europe you
probably still would have been captured
and burned at the stake under the
assumption that you're a demon uh but
you might be able to reason with them
there's a chance but landing in Peru
now you're dealing with I guess at that
point like the Inca I think or maybe
whatever the pre-inka tribe was and now
you've got human sacrifices going on so
I guarantee I guarantee they landed
there's a whole group of them these
adorable little Ewoks they landed and
most of them were immediately captured
and scalped and butchered and you could
just imagine them strolling up to the
Incan uh death Temple and just naively
and they're like hey folks just uh
stopping by from planet neptun or
whatever just wanted to say hi and then
boom one of them is hit in the face with
a spear and it's a bloodbath and the two
survivors they run into a cave and they
hide and they're just looking at each
other like holy crap man what the hell
kind of planet is this we this is not
this is the wrong solar system we need
to get out of here and you can actually
see them you can see them cringing you
know he's he he died cringing they're
just cringing they're like geez
this place is rough
and they died of starvation or whatever
you know or of exposure they died of the
cold and maybe they got bit by a
rattlesnake or something that's my
theory and um
and that's it and that's what happened
and that's my analysis and I'm happy to
provide this testimony uh to the Mexican
Government that's the whole story
of beep and Bop
that I've spent seven minutes on
what during what's supposed to be a new
segment if you'd like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed